"I'll pour this pestilence into his ear. So will I make the net that will enmesh them all." It's an adult, Iago, who says that in Othello. And it's grownups that Machiavelli was writing about when he wrote The Prince , his book about manipulating others and seizing power. Notice he titled the book The Prince , not The Little Prince. The Little Prince is actually by somebody else, if you don't know that.
“我要将这瘟疫灌入他的耳中。我将编织一张网，将他们一网打尽。”这是奥赛罗中伊阿古说的话。马基雅维利在写《君主论》——那本关于操纵他人和攫取权力的书——时，所谈论的也是成年人。请注意，他把书名定为《君主论》（The Prince），而不是《小王子》（The Little Prince）。如果你不知道的话，其实《小王子》是另一个人写的。
But in our American lives, the real era of intrigue and manipulation for most of us is not adulthood. It's adolescence, when our social circle is at its most constricting. Today on our program, a story of betrayal and of someone who holds David Koresh-like powers over others, and who is only in the seventh grade. From WBEZ in Chicago, it's Your Radio Playhouse . I'm Ira Glass.
但在我们美国人的生活中，对大多数人而言，真正的阴谋与操纵时代并非成年，而是青春期，那时我们的社交圈最狭窄。今天在我们的节目中，将讲述一个背叛的故事，主角是一个像大卫·考雷什一样对他人拥有掌控力的人，而他仅仅是一名七年级的学生。这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《你的广播剧场》（Your Radio Playhouse）。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
But before we get into the body of our story, we will try, as adults, to manipulate you a little bit at Pledge Central. Let's check in with Pledge Central. Shirley Jahad.
但在进入故事正题之前，我们要以成年人的身份，在捐款中心稍微操纵一下大家。让我们连线捐款中心，雪莉·贾哈德。
Hi, Ira Glass.
你好，艾拉·格拉斯。
Hi.
你好。
We're trying to manipulate the Radio Playhouse listeners, are we?
我们是在试图操纵“广播剧场”的听众吗？
I guess "manipulate" has the tune of a negative connotation.
我想“操纵”这个词带有一种负面的暗示。
Oh, encourage, cajole, lure, maybe?
哦，是鼓励、哄劝、诱导，或许吧？
Yeah, and we have all these--
是的，我们有所有这些——
Entice, how about?
诱惑，怎么样？
Entice. Entice is a very--
诱惑。诱惑是一个非常——
Seduce?
勾引？
Keep going, baby. You're on a roll. You're on such a roll here. Sure.
继续，宝贝。你状态不错。你现在状态真是好极了。当然。
Well, let's seduce them with this phone number.
好吧，让我们用这个电话号码来勾引他们。
What is the phone number?
电话号码是多少？
We've got to seduce them with this phone number. 312-832-3160. Stop the music dramatically as I say the number.
我们必须用这个号码来勾引他们。312-832-3160。在我念号码的时候戏剧性地停掉音乐。
Do it again.
再来一次。
312-832-3160. Maybe a little radio hypnotism. 312-832-3160. Call that number to pledge your support.
312-832-3160。也许来点无线电催眠。312-832-3160。拨打这个号码来承诺你的支持。
And I just want to say that we are so anxious to get you to call. We have very special premiums that we're offering during the coming hour that are available at no other time during the drive. We have three and a half or four, depending on how you count them. The very first one-- I'm going to play a little clip of these. These are all audio things. Well, how to begin with this?
我只想说，我们非常渴望你们打电话来。我们在接下来的一个小时内提供非常特别的礼品，这些礼品在活动期间其他任何时间都无法获得。我们有三个半或四个，取决于你怎么算。第一个——我要播放一小段这些东西的剪辑。这些都是音频资料。好吧，怎么开始呢？
Explain it, Ira.
解释一下，艾拉。
Well, one of them is we have a cassette of recent work by David Sedaris, much of it heard here on Your Radio Playhouse , some of it heard on Morning Edition . This is all new work, including two radio dramas by the Pinetree Gang, which appear here on Your Radio Playhouse . That's one thing.
好吧，其中之一是我们有戴维·塞达里斯近期作品的磁带，很多曾在《你的广播剧场》中播放过，有些则在《早间版》（Morning Edition）中播出过。这都是新作品，包括两部由松树帮（Pinetree Gang）制作的广播剧，它们也出现在《你的广播剧场》中。这是第一样。
Another thing is we have this very odd CD called Shut Up, Little Man , which listeners to the show heard. It's a sort of audio verite of these two men recorded through the walls of their apartment as they argued with each other.
另一样是我们有一张非常古怪的CD，叫《闭嘴，小人》（Shut Up, Little Man），节目听众听过。这是一种音频真实记录，是这两个人通过公寓墙壁争吵时被录下来的。
And finally, we have this thing. Two weeks ago, we had a show where Julia Sweeney told the story of getting cancer. And she told the story of herself getting cancer and of her brother getting cancer. And she told them as stand-up comedy. And she was telling this in a place called Un-Cabaret. It's a club in Los Angeles where essentially, comics come each week, and they tell what are basically comic diary versions of their week.
最后，我们有这个。两周前，我们做了一期节目，朱莉娅·斯威尼讲述了她患癌症的故事。她讲述了自己患癌和她兄弟患癌的故事。她是以单口喜剧的形式讲述的。她在一家叫Un-Cabaret的地方讲的。这是洛杉矶的一家俱乐部，基本上喜剧演员每周都会来这里，讲述他们一周生活的喜剧日记版本。
And Un-Cabaret has a CD that's really pretty wonderful with some well-known people and some not-so-well-known people. And here's a sample. They have about 10 minutes of Julia Sweeney's cancer stories. Here's a sample of that.
Un-Cabaret有一张CD非常棒，里面有一些知名人士，也有一些不那么出名的人。这是一个片段。他们有大约10分钟朱莉娅·斯威尼的癌症故事。这是其中的一段。
OK, so we're in the doctor's office, and Mike, who's doing really great and is responding really well to the treatment. But he's had so many spinal taps that they can't get into his spinal column anymore. So the doctor comes in. My dad's reading about the plague in India, because that's a good diversion. And my mom is looking at the doctors and saying, "Now, he looks single."
好的，我们在医生的办公室里，迈克表现得非常好，对治疗反应也很理想。但他做了太多次腰椎穿刺，医生已经没法再从他的脊柱进针了。医生进来了。我爸在读关于印度鼠疫的书，因为那是很好的消遣。而我妈看着医生说：“嗯，他看起来单身。”
And his doctor comes in. He says, "Michael, we can't get into your spinal column anymore, so we're thinking about putting a shunt in your head. And my brother goes, "What?" He goes, "A shunt?" And I go, "A shunt, like, an artificial opening to the brain." And Mike goes, "Well, where would this shunt be?" And the doctor goes, "Well, the best place we've found is to put it in the forehead."
他的医生进来了。他说：“迈克尔，我们没法再进入你的脊柱了，所以我们正在考虑在你的头上放一个分流器。”我兄弟说：“什么？”他说：“一个分流器？”我说：“一个分流器，就像通往大脑的人造开口。”迈克说：“那么，这个分流器会放在哪里？”医生说：“好吧，我们找到的最佳位置是放在额头上。”
And Mike goes, "If you think I am going to get a faucet put into my forehead. I'm already 90 pounds, and I have no hair. I'm not going to walk around for a year with a faucet sticking out of my forehead." And my mom goes, "No, I think it's more like a spigot."
迈克说：“如果你以为我要在额头上装个水龙头，你就错了。我已经只有90磅重了，还没头发。我可不想带着一个从额头伸出来的水龙头到处走一年。”我妈说：“不，我觉得它更像是一个栓塞。”
All right, so that's Julia Sweeney. If you want that and more-- and more diary entries from Janeane Garofalo and people who seem less well known. But there's Julia Sweeney, Janeane Garofalo, Beth Lapides, Bob Goldthwait, Taylor Negron, Dana Gould, other people. Ask for that when you call. 832-3160. Shirley, you're still there, right?
好了，这就是朱莉娅·斯威尼。如果你想要这个以及更多内容——以及更多来自珍妮·加罗法洛和那些看似不太出名的人的日记。但这里有朱莉娅·斯威尼、珍妮·加罗法洛、贝丝·拉皮德斯、鲍勃·高斯韦特、泰勒·内格龙、达纳·古尔德和其他人。当你打电话时请索要这个。832-3160。雪莉，你还在那儿，对吧？
832-3160, yeah.
832-3160，是的。
And, Shirley, what is the magic word? We haven't even gotten to the extra-special premium. What is the magic word?
那么，雪莉，魔咒是什么？我们甚至还没谈到那个超级特别的赠品。魔咒是什么？
Oh, the extra-special $4.95-- for $4.95, you can super size it.
哦，那个超级特别的4.95美元——只需4.95美元，你就可以升级它（super size it）。
You can super size it. That's right. If you make the $60 pledge and just say super size it, for another $4.95, you get--
你可以升级它。没错。如果你承诺捐款60美元，只需说“升级它”，再加4.95美元，你就能得到——
More "La Bamba" than you can handle.
比你所能承受的更多的《拉班巴》（La Bamba）。
Here we go. I think I've got it. This one starts kind of slow. This is a punk "La Bamba." They have a little collection of all sorts of "La Bambas." It's one of the most covered songs in music. We have the Mormon Tabernacle Choir. We have punk versions. We have Neil Diamond. This is kind of a surf version. Again, we want you to pledge. We want to please you.
开始吧。我想我搞定了。这一首开始得有点慢。这是一个朋克版的《拉班巴》。他们有一个各种各样的《拉班巴》合集。这是音乐界翻唱次数最多的歌曲之一。我们有摩门会幕合唱团版本，有朋克版本，还有尼尔·戴蒙德版本。这是一种冲浪版本。再说一遍，我们希望你捐款。我们想取悦你。
We want you to pledge and then to super size it. 312-832-3160. Come on, go for extra fries and an extra large drink. 312-832-3160. Sorry, Ira.
我们希望你捐款然后升级它。312-832-3160。来吧，点一份特大薯条和一杯特大饮料。312-832-3160。抱歉，艾拉。
No, that's OK. So the idea is 60 bucks for one of the premia and $64.95 for one of the premia plus--
不，没关系。所以想法是60美元换取其中一个礼品，64.95美元换取其中一个礼品加上——
90 minutes of "La Bamba." Take it on vacation with you, right? To the Caribbean.
90分钟的《拉班巴》。带去度假吧，好吗？去加勒比海。
It makes a fine, fine summertime present for anyone.
这对于任何人来说都是一份非常棒的暑期礼物。
That's right. 312-832-3160. Call now to pledge your support for Your Radio Playhouse.
就是这样。312-832-3160。现在就拨打电话来承诺支持《你的广播剧场》。
OK, Shirley. I'll check back with you in a bit.
好的，雪莉。我过会儿再找你。
Thanks, Ira.
谢谢，艾拉。
So let's get to today's story on this, our radio show. This is a story of enemies. But some of the bitterest enemies are people who used to be close friends. And our story begins with the friendship of these two boys named Bob and Dave. And today's program will be in four acts. Act One, Dave's Love.
那么让我们进入今天我们广播节目的故事。这是一个关于敌人的故事。但一些最苦涩的敌人往往是曾经的密友。我们的故事从两个名叫鲍勃和戴夫的男孩的友谊开始。今天的节目分为四幕。第一幕，戴夫的爱。
Act Two, Dave's Hate.
第二幕，戴夫的恨。
Act Three, Dave Today.
第三幕，今天的戴夫。
Act Four, Another Dave. That another Dave is David Sedaris, actually. We have a story by David Sedaris coming up.
第四幕，另一个戴夫。那个另一个戴夫其实就是戴维·塞达里斯。我们接下来有一个戴维·塞达里斯的故事。
So, Act One. Our story takes place in a small town somewhere on the East Coast.
那么，第一幕。我们的故事发生在一个东海岸的小镇上。
Dave and I became friends in fourth grade, and we were friends through sixth grade. And I have to describe him physically because that's a huge part of his personality. He was-- and he still is-- an extremely wiry person. Very thin. He looks emaciated. And he also, his skin is like a jaundiced yellow color. He was always very acned. Just very pale, pasty, and he just looked sick.
戴夫和我在四年级成为朋友，一直到六年级我们都是好朋友。我必须从外表描述他，因为那是他个性中很大的一部分。他非常瘦弱——现在依然如此。他看起来面黄肌瘦。而且，他的皮肤呈现一种黄疸般的黄色。他总是长满痤疮。看起来脸色苍白、蜡黄，总是一副病恹恹的样子。
I don't really know how we became friends. We were in class together in grade school. But as things progressed into fifth grade, it became pretty clear that our friendship was the most intense friendship in the class. We would talk on the phone at least once a day and for hours. We would just talk for hours and just make each other laugh so hard. And that was why we always got separated in class was just because we weren't troublemakers, we just made each other laugh a lot. We had very similar senses of humor.
我不确定我们是怎么成为朋友的。我们在小学时就在同一个班。但随着五年级的推进，很明显我们的友谊是班里最深厚的。我们每天至少通一次电话，一聊就是几个小时。我们只是不停地聊天，把对方逗得大笑。我们总是被老师分开，并不是因为我们捣乱，只是因为我们太能逗对方笑了。我们的幽默感非常相似。
The scatological jokes were the primary jokes. And I was just thinking about this today. I remembered this one thing that we used to do, which we did obsessively. It's embarrassing to say it, but we were obsessed with the words "poop" and "pee." And we made this little thing where I would say "poop" and he would say "pee," and then he would say "wee," and then I would say "gilly gee." And so it'd go kind of like, poop, pee, wee, gilly gee. And we said this over and over and over again. And we used to just take books and just insert the words "poop" and "pee" everywhere.
厕所笑话是我们的主要谈资。我今天还在想这件事。我想起了我们过去常常做的一件事，我们对此非常痴迷。说出来有点尴尬，但我们沉迷于“大便”（poop）和“小便”（pee）这两个词。我们搞了个小把戏，我说“大便”，他说“小便”，然后他说“嘘嘘”（wee），然后我说“吉利吉”（gilly gee）。所以就像是：大便、小便、嘘嘘、吉利吉。我们一遍又一遍地重复这个。我们还经常拿课本，在里面到处填上“大便”和“小便”。
And "wee" was like the one word that was just, for some reason, that was like our rallying call. That was like our motto. We just said it all the time. Just "wee." Wee! We used to do that all the time. Wee!
而且“嘘嘘”那个词，出于某种原因，成了我们的集结号。那是我们的座右铭。我们总是说它。就只是“嘘嘘”。嘘嘘！我们总是那样做。嘘嘘！
Some of the other stuff that we had in common-- our favorite group was The Village People. And we used to listen to The Village People all the time and just totally obsess about them, having no idea what they were singing about at all. And the Dukes of Hazzard was another one, and Star Wars . Those were very big things. And sports.
我们还有其他共同点——我们最喜欢的团体是“乡村乐队”（The Village People）。我们总是听他们的歌，完全沉迷其中，却完全不知道他们唱的是什么。还有《哈扎德公爵》（Dukes of Hazzard）和《星球大战》。那些都是很重大的事情。还有运动。
I basically discovered sexuality through him. And we used to play spin the bottle in his room. And we would take off an article of clothing when it would land on us. And it was the first time we'd ever been naked in front of another person except for our parents. And it was petrifying, but it was also just this whole discovery period of seeing another man naked there.
我基本上是通过他发现性取向的。我们过去常在他的房间里玩转瓶子游戏。瓶子转到谁，谁就脱掉一件衣服。这是我们第一次在父母以外的人面前赤身裸体。这很吓人，但这也是一个发现过程，看到另一个男人赤裸的样子。
And it became this whole game that we played often. And we would revel in the fact of standing there in front of each other totally naked, assuming these characters like, "Hi, Mr. Jones. How are you? Nice to meet you." Businessmen and everything, just standing there completely buck naked and so terrified that we were ever going to get caught, because his parents were always home. They were always in the house and everything, and we were just so afraid that someone was going to knock on the door.
这成了一个我们经常玩的游戏。我们喜欢在那儿彼此赤裸相对，扮演角色，比如：“嗨，琼斯先生。你好吗？很高兴见到你。”扮演商人之类的，就那样完全一丝不挂地站着，又非常害怕被抓到，因为他的父母总是在家。他们总是在屋子里，我们非常害怕有人会敲门。
The one time that was the biggest scare was he-- Dave basically could get anybody to do anything that he wanted them to do. And he had a camera and was-- these times when I'd go up to his house were fully documented events. He's very anal retentive. And he loved documenting everything was going on.
最惊险的一次是——戴夫基本上能让任何人做任何他想让他们做的事。他有一台相机——我去他家的时候都被记录了下来。他有很强的强迫症。他喜欢记录发生的一切。
So he would have a camera and take a lot of pictures. And he wanted me to pull down my pants and take a picture of me with my pants down. And I was refusing to do it. I would not let it be caught on film. And he was just insisting, and he went through this entire-- I mean, he was trying to coax me for so long, telling me all these different things that he was going to do for me and saying, "Oh, nobody's going to see it." And he came up with this whole scheme of how nobody would see the film and everything and just these elaborate, elaborate plans on how nobody would see these pictures. And I just kept refusing and refusing and refusing.
所以他会拿相机拍很多照片。他想让我脱掉裤子，拍一张我脱裤子的照片。我一直拒绝。我绝不允许这被拍进胶卷里。他一直坚持，他经历了整个过程——我的意思是，他试图劝诱我很久，跟我说他会为我做所有这些事，说：“哦，没人会看到的。”他想出了一个周密的计划，说没人会看到底片等等，这些精心策划的方案。但我一直在拒绝。
And finally, at the end of it, he was like, "All right, just take down you pants anyway. I won't take a picture. I swear to you. I won't take a picture, I promise." And I still didn't believe him. And he was like, "Look, I promise. I promise. I promise," This went on for like an hour, of him trying to coax me to take my pants down. And he promised me, bottom of his heart, that he was not going to take a picture.
最后，他干脆说：“好吧，反正把裤子脱了吧。我不会拍照。我向你发誓。我不会拍照，我保证。”我还是不信他。他说：“看，我保证。我保证。我保证。”这持续了一个小时，他试图劝诱我脱下裤子。他向我发自肺腑地保证，他不会拍照。
And so I was like, fine. So I like unbuckled my belt, and I unbuckled my pants. And I pulled down my zipper, and I whipped open my pants. And I had my underwear on. And then I put myself all back together again. And when I had my pants open, he took a picture. And I was like, "Ah!"
所以我就想，好吧。于是我解开皮带，拉开拉链，掀开了裤子。我穿着内衣。然后我又穿好衣服。就在我拉开裤子的时候，他拍了一张照片。我当时就喊：“啊！”
And I was terrified because when you're that age, when you're 11 and 12 years old, you can't go in and get your pictures developed yourself and pay for them and get them. And I thought, somebody is going to get these pictures developed, and somebody is going to see them.
我吓坏了，因为在这个年纪，当你11岁或12岁时，你不能自己去把照片洗出来并付费。我心想，有人会去洗这些照片，有人会看到它们。
So weeks later, I was going up to his house again. And in the car going up to his house-- his mother was driving-- he was like, "I got the pictures back." And I said, "Oh, my god." And he was like, "You're not going to believe what's on there." And I said, "But what can be? You didn't see anything." And he's like, "I know, but you have to see this because it's there." And I was like, "But it can't be because I didn't take my pants down." And he was like, "I know, but it's there. It's there. You have to see it."
几周后，我又要去他家了。在去他家的车里——他母亲在开车——他说：“我拿到照片了。”我说：“天哪。”他说：“你不会相信照片上有什么。”我说：“能有什么？你什么都没看到。”他说：“我知道，但你必须看，因为它就在那儿。”我说：“不可能，因为我没脱下裤子。”他说：“我知道，但它就在那儿。就在那儿。你必须看。”
He pulls out the pictures, and I looked at it. And my penis was hanging out there. And I was like, "But I didn't do it." And he was like, "You must've." And I said, "But I know I didn't. I know I just opened my pants." And he said, "You must've done it. Maybe it just fell out or something." And I said, "But it can't be." And we racked our brains just trying to figure out what had happened, because I knew that I hadn't pulled my underwear down.
他拿出照片，我看了一下。我的阴茎露在外面。我说：“但我没做那种事。”他说：“你肯定做了。”我说：“但我知道我没做。我知道我只是拉开了裤子。”他说：“你一定是做了。也许它只是掉了出来之类的。”我说：“这不可能。”我们绞尽脑汁试图弄清楚发生了什么，因为我知道我没有把内衣脱下来。
So that night, we were at a high school football game. And we were looking at the pictures again, just examining them. We were way up in the bleachers in a corner. And we took them out, and we were looking at them. And we were trying to explain what had happened. And finally, we figured out that it was the inside of my belt that looked like my penis.
那天晚上，我们在看高中橄榄球比赛。我们又拿出照片在看，仔细研究。我们在看台最高处的角落里。我们拿出照片，一边看着，一边试图解释发生了什么。最后，我们发现原来是我皮带的内侧看起来像阴茎。
And we're like, "Oh!" And so I was completely relieved, but I made him-- I watched him just tear up the picture into a thousand pieces and went through this whole elaborate method to bury the pieces in the bottom of a trash can at this football stadium. And I was still petrified that somebody was going to find them and piece them together.
我们惊呼：“哦！”所以我完全松了一口气，但我让他——我看着他把那张照片撕成了碎片，并执行了一个极其复杂的办法，把这些碎片埋在了球场垃圾桶的底部。但我还是很害怕有人会发现并把它们拼凑起来。
The point that it started to change was, as we were going into sixth grade, we were constantly being separated in class. And that's around the time when people start to realize that there's a difference between someone who's straight and someone who's gay. And there was just grumblings happening. People were accusing us of being homosexual.
情况开始转变是在我们进入六年级的时候，我们在课堂上不断被分开。那是人们开始意识到异性恋和同性恋之间区别的时候。到处都有流言蜚语。人们指责我们是同性恋。
And we weren't in any way, but we also knew of all the things that we had done with each other in each other's presence. And I think when people started to think that we were gay, that just rose to the surface, and we realized that there was a cool thing and a not cool thing. And we were definitely not cool in the friendship that we were in.
我们根本不是，但我们也知道我们在彼此面前做过的所有那些事。我认为当人们开始认为我们是同性恋时，那些事就浮出了水面，我们意识到有些东西是酷的，有些则是不酷的。在我们的友谊中，我们绝对是不酷的。
And that's also around that time when-- in my town, at least, and I think in a lot of small towns-- is where sports just become the most important thing in your life. And I was not a good athlete then at all. Dave was a good athlete. And Dave organized a big football party one weekend where we were going to go out there and play football and have a sleepover and then the next day, play more football.
那也是在我家乡，至少我认为在许多小镇上，运动成为生活中最重要事情的时候。我那时根本不是个好运动员。戴夫是个好运动员。那个周末，戴夫组织了一个盛大的橄榄球派对，我们要去玩橄榄球，还要举行过夜聚会，第二天继续打。
Dave just organized this thing unbelievably. He had jerseys printed up with numbers and names on them. He had teams with rosters. He had practice for his team with plays. There was a playbook. This is for a little football game, like three-on-three football or four-on-four football. Touch football.
戴夫把这事组织得简直不可思议。他印制了带有号码和名字的球衣。他有分好队伍的名单。他甚至带他的球队进行有战术安排的练习。有一本战术手册。这只是一场小型的橄榄球比赛，比如三对三或四对四的触碰式橄榄球。
And every single minute was decided upon beforehand by him as to what we would do, where we would be, what we would eat, the food we would eat, when we would play football. It was all timed out. He was so organized and anal retentive about it. I don't remember very well, but I can't imagine that I played tremendously well.
每一分钟都被他提前决定好了，我们要做什么，在哪儿，吃什么，什么时候打球。全都有时间表。他在这些事情上非常有组织性和强迫症。我记不太清了，但我无法想象我当时表现得有多好。
I was thinking about this today. I was trying to think of the moment when everything changed. And I'm almost positive it was that event. It was the football party. And immediately after that, he just totally stopped talking to me.
我今天在想这件事。我试图想出一切改变的那一刻。我几乎可以肯定就是那个活动。橄榄球派对。在那之后，他就完全不跟我说话了。
How Dave turned the class against Bob, as our show continues.
戴夫是如何让全班同学反对鲍勃的，我们的节目继续。
Well, it is Your Radio Playhouse. And we do want you to call 832-3160. Area code 312. Hey, Shirley Jahad, are you there?
这里是《你的广播剧场》。我们要你拨打832-3160。区号312。嘿，雪莉·贾哈德，你在吗？
Hey, Ira Glass.
嘿，艾拉·格拉斯。
Hey, honey.
嘿，亲爱的。
This is an intriguing little tale.
这是一个引人入胜的小故事。
Well, as we try to present here on this, our little Radio Playhouse radio show. Are people calling?
好吧，就像我们在这个小广播剧场节目中试图呈现的那样。有人打电话吗？
People are calling. 312-832-3160. I don't have the exact count yet, but the phones are ringing. And people are super-sizing their pledges.
有人在打电话。312-832-3160。我还没有确切的统计数字，但电话一直在响。人们在升级他们的捐款。
Wait, you said the magic word, which means I have to get rid of this music and bring on-- here it is. Do you recognize this, Shirley?
等等，你说了那个魔咒，这意味着我必须处理掉这些音乐，然后引出——就是这个。你认出这个了吗，雪莉？
Could it be? It's a familiar yet foreign.
难道是？这既熟悉又陌生。
This is the Mormon Tabernacle Choir version of "La Bamba," which appears to you when you say the word "super size."
这是摩门会幕合唱团版本的《拉班巴》，当你说了“升级它”这个词时，它就会出现。
Super size your pledge for $4.95, and you get 90 minutes of "La Bamba."
额外多捐4.95美元升级你的承诺，你就能得到90分钟的《拉班巴》。
Blessing or a curse. And remember our three special premia. One is the Un-Cabaret CD, which is basically comics telling stories about their own lives. The second thing is the Shut Up, Little Man CD. And the third thing is David Sedaris, including lots of material heard on this program, but also, for example, the Christmas--
是福还是祸。记住我们三个特别赠品。一个是Un-Cabaret CD，基本上是喜剧演员讲述自己生活的故事。第二样是《闭嘴，小人》CD。第三样是戴维·塞达里斯的作品，包括本节目中听到的许多素材，但也有，比如圣诞——
SantaLand Diaries.
《圣诞乐园日记》（SantaLand Diaries）。
No, I feel like we've given that away too many times. I'm sorry. But this year, David did a story for Morning Edition that we had to cut about three minutes out to fit it into a Morning Edition segment. People who buy the cassette will get the uncut version. And it's the story about how he was having a bad Christmas one year until his sister brought home a prostitute who she knew from work.
不，我觉得那段我们放太多次了。抱歉。但今年，戴维为《早间版》写了一个故事，我们为了配合《早间版》的栏目不得不剪掉了三分钟。购买磁带的听众将得到未剪辑版。故事是关于他有一年圣诞节过得很糟糕，直到他妹妹从工作中带回一个妓女。
"What were the prison guards really like?" Amy asked. "Which do you like better, spending the night with strange guys or working in a cafeteria?" Tiffany tried on Donna's shoes while Gretchen modeled her jacket.
“监狱守卫真的像那样吗？”艾米问。“你更喜欢和陌生的男人过夜，还是在自助餐厅工作？”蒂芙尼试穿了唐娜的鞋子，而格雷琴在展示她的外套。
"Donna the Christmas Whore."
“圣诞妓女唐娜”。
Oh, my. Ho, ho, ho.
哦，天哪。吼，吼，吼。
Yeah, ho, ho, ho. And what's the number again?
是的，吼，吼，吼。号码是多少来着？
312-832-3160.
312-832-3160。
A heart-warming story for the whole family.
一个温暖人心的故事，适合全家观看。
Like this one we're in the middle of. 312-832-3160. A slew of premiums. All kinds of great comedy and performance and storytelling and wonderful music. 90-minute cassette of "La Bamba" in many varieties. 312-832-3160. If you say "super size it," those volunteers will know what you mean.
就像我们正在讲述的这个。312-832-3160。海量的赠品。各种精彩的喜剧、表演、故事讲述和美妙的音乐。90分钟的各种版本的《拉班巴》磁带。312-832-3160。如果你说“升级它”，志愿者们就会明白你的意思。
In fact, you can get any premium that the station is selling. Anything. Anything you've heard all day and that you're going to hear all week, and just say "super size it." Only during this show. At $4.95, you get that "La Bamba" tape.
事实上，你可以得到电台正在出售的任何礼品。任何东西。任何你今天听到的、本周会听到的东西，只要说“升级它”。仅限于本节目期间。只需4.95美元，你就能得到那盘《拉班巴》磁带。
Your Radio Playhouse . 312-832-3160.
《你的广播剧场》。312-832-3160。
Check back with you later, Shirley.
过会儿再找你，雪莉。
Thanks, Ira.
谢谢，艾拉。
Act Two, Dave's Hatred. Dave and Bob were best friends. And now Dave started using all the tactics that adults use in political situations, in power situations, all the tactics one uses to turn people against one another. Whispering in ears, things like that. Bob, who's now a theater director in New York City, by the way, Bob tells the story.
第二幕，戴夫的憎恨。戴夫和鲍勃曾经是最好的朋友。现在戴夫开始使用成人在政治局势、权力斗争中使用的所有策略，那种让人们反目成仇的手段。耳语、类似的事情。鲍勃，顺便说一句，他现在是纽约市的一名戏剧导演，他讲述了这个故事。
I remember going into class in seventh grade on the first day of school and him not talking to me and everybody just wondering. The whole school was wondering why there was this big fight going on between Dave and Bob. And I remember not having an answer for anybody. I used to tell them to ask Dave. I had no idea. And I used to tell people that he just stopped talking to me. And I remember that he became completely bent on turning everyone against me. The whole school. And he did it very well because he's so organized and because he's so manipulative.
我记得七年级开学第一天走进教室，他不跟我说话，每个人都在纳闷。全校都在纳闷为什么戴夫和鲍勃之间有这么大的冲突。我记得对任何人都没有答案。我过去常告诉他们去问戴夫。我根本不知道。我告诉人们他只是停止跟我说话了。我记得他完全一心想要让所有人反对我。全校。他做得非常好，因为他非常有组织性，而且他非常擅长操纵。
And I saw him. And I saw him telling people to say things to me. And he was one who formed the I Hate-- they used to call me [? Cooze ?] then. And he was the one who formed the I Hate [? Cooze ?] Club. He never did anything to me himself. He would never come up to me and make fun of me. He would never come up to me and hit me. He would never assault me personally. But he would just get everyone else to do it for him.
我看着他。我看着他让别人说那些话来针对我。是他组建了“我恨[？]俱乐部”。他自己从来没有对我做过什么。他从不走过来嘲笑我。他从不走过来打我。他从未对我进行过人身攻击。但他就是让其他人替他做这一切。
So he would send people to say things to me. I remember one time in the lunchroom Sam saying, have you ever been caught masturbating? And of course, either answer is-- you damn yourself if you answer yes or if you answer no. And I remember hearing Dave tell him to ask me that.
他会派人来说那些话。我记得有一次在午餐室，萨姆说，你有没有被抓到过手淫？当然，无论你怎么回答——如果你回答是或不是，你都完了。我记得听到戴夫叫他问我那个问题。
I used to just get made fun of horrendously by everyone. People would make fun of the way that I chewed at lunch. People would make fun of the way that I laughed. People would make fun of the way that I coughed, that I sneezed. People would make fun of the way that I walked. There was just this teasing. But that makes it even sound less violent than it was. It was just a mocking. It was a very pointed mocking on everyone's part.
我过去常常被所有人极其残忍地嘲笑。人们嘲笑我午饭时咀嚼的方式。人们嘲笑我笑的方式。人们嘲笑我咳嗽、打喷嚏的方式。人们嘲笑我走路的方式。到处都是这种戏弄。但说“戏弄”听起来比实际情况要轻。那是一种赤裸裸的嘲弄。每个人都在进行有针对性的嘲弄。
I remember sitting alone at the lunch table with no one to talk to and just wanting so badly for no one to turn their attention to me because I knew that the attention would be negative. I remember not understanding what was going on. I had been in such a sweet position with this person. We had such a good friendship. And then, all of a sudden, everyone had just turned against me.
我记得独自坐在午餐桌旁，没有人和我说话，我非常渴望没人把注意力放在我身上，因为我知道那注意力一定是负面的。我不明白发生了什么。我曾和这个人处于那么甜蜜的位置。我们曾有过那么好的友谊。然后，突然之间，所有人都反过来对付我。
And he wasn't like a pied piper. He was so subtle, and he was so quiet. I don't think he ever had a friendship with people like he had with me. But he was just able to organize people into these different factions. He would just say, "Go over to [? Cooze ?] and just shove him into a locker." And they'd go do it.
他不像吹笛人。他是那么微妙，那么安静。我想他从未像跟我那样跟别人建立过友谊。但他就是能把人们组织成不同的派系。他只会说：“去[？]那里，把他推到储物柜里。”他们就会去照做。
That was the worst period, I think, of my entire life was that period. I used to go home from school and cry after school. I used to go to my dog and hug my dog and say, you are my only friend in the world.
我认为那是我一生中最糟糕的时期。放学后，我经常回家哭。我曾抱着我的狗说，你是我世界上唯一的朋友。
Then he started to kind of needle me. I remember one thing that he did was there was this guy, Mike, in my class. And Mike was what we called in my hometown a scummer, which meant that he was on welfare. He perhaps didn't have a pair of pants for every day of the week. He was very smart, which was a strike against him at that age. And he just didn't fit in. He was a real geek. So Dave organized this fight between Mike and I-- a fist fight to prove who was the bigger faggot. Whoever would lose was the bigger faggot.
然后他开始折磨我。我记得他做过的一件事，班里有个叫迈克的家伙。迈克在我们家乡被称为“社会渣滓”，意思是他靠救济金生活。他可能一周都没有几条裤子换洗。他非常聪明，但在那个年纪，这反而是他的弱点。他完全不合群。他是个十足的怪胎。所以戴夫策划了我和迈克之间的打斗——一场肉搏战，来证明谁才是更大的娘娘腔。谁输了，谁就是更大的娘娘腔。
And he positioned us-- he spun it so there was no way I could not fight. If I didn't have this fight, then things would just get worse for me. Things would get worse. Mike was at the bottom of the barrel, and I was there with him. And Dave had to prove that I was below him. And so he organized this whole fight. And everyone in the class was like, "Are you going to fight Mike? Are you going to fight Mike?"
他设了局——他把事情搞得我根本无法拒绝打架。如果不打，情况只会更糟。迈克在社会最底层，我就和他在一起。戴夫必须证明我比他更低。于是他组织了整场打斗。全班都在说：“你要和迈克打吗？你要和迈克打吗？”
And I finally conceded. I conceded to fight him. Dave organized the whole event. It was to happen at this playground. And we went, and he tried to get this whole audience to come and see it. Unfortunately, nobody came but him-- well, I guess, fortunately. Nobody came but him and one other person.
最后我妥协了。我同意跟他打。戴夫组织了整个活动。地点定在操场上。我们去了，他试图让所有人都来看。不幸的是，没人来，除了他——嗯，我想，幸运的是。没人来，只有他和另外一个人。
So Mike and I went there. And neither of us wanted to fight each other. Neither of us had any reason in the world to fight each other. So I just remember standing there facing him, just laughing, just like, what are we supposed to do? We're standing here. We've been forced into this just to save our own souls. And now we have to inflict pain on each other. And we stood there for the longest time. And Dave kept trying to push us into fighting. He was saying, "Come on. Just throw a punch. Just throw a punch. Just start."
所以迈克和我都去了。我们谁都不想打架。我们根本没有理由打架。我只记得站在那里面对他，大笑着，心想，我们到底该干什么？我们站在这里。我们被强迫这么做，只是为了保全自己的自尊。而现在我们必须伤害彼此。我们站了很久。戴夫一直在催促我们打架。他说：“来吧。挥一拳。挥一拳。开始吧。”
We waited for the longest time, and then finally, I was just like, this is ridiculous. So I went up, and I shoved him. And then we started to fight. We weren't really into fighting, but we had to do it then. And I pushed him at one point, and he fell backwards and he hurt his wrist. And I got on top of him. and I held his wrist. And I remember saying to him, "Do you give up?" And he wouldn't give up. And I was holding his wrist back.
我们等了很久，最后，我实在受不了了，心想，这太荒谬了。于是我走过去，推了他一把。然后我们就开始打。我们并不是真的想打，但当时不得不这么做。有一次我推他，他向后跌倒，弄伤了手腕。我压在他身上。我抓着他的手腕。我记得对他喊道：“你认输吗？”他不认输。我把他的手腕往后扳。
And each time I kept asking if he was going to give up, and he kept saying no. And each time he'd say no, I'd bend his wrist back a little bit more. And he was crying in pain. And I kept saying, I'm going to bend it back. I'm going to bend it back. I'm going to bend it back, thinking, I don't want to break this person's wrist. I have no reason to break this person's wrist.
每次我问他是否认输，他都说不。每当他说不，我就把他的手腕再往后扳一点。他在痛苦地哭泣。我一直说，我要把它扳断。我要把它扳断。我要把它扳断。心想，我不想弄断这人的手腕。我没有理由弄断这人的手腕。
And I was faced at that moment with either giving up and getting kicked even more or going ahead with really hurting this person and hoping that it would save me in some way. And I broke his wrist. He came in the next day into school with a cast on. I don't know how his family paid for his cast. And everybody saw that and said, "You idiot, [? Cooze! ?] What did you do? You idiot!" And it made it even worse.
那一刻，我面临两个选择：要么放弃，被踢得更惨；要么继续，真的伤害这个人，希望这能以某种方式救我。我弄断了他的手腕。第二天他打着石膏来上学。我不知道他的家人是怎么支付石膏费用的。每个人都看到了，说：“你这白痴，[？]！你干了什么？你这个白痴！”这让情况变得更糟了。
I just didn't understand. I didn't know what was going on. That's the most frustrating for me, even still today. I always thought it was me. I always thought it was something I was doing. I thought it was the way that I wore my clothes. I thought it was the shoes that I wore. I thought it was the way that I laughed. I remember.
我根本不明白。我不知道发生了什么。即使到今天，那也是最让我沮丧的。我一直认为是我的错。我一直认为是因为我的某些行为。我以为是我的衣着方式。我以为是穿的鞋子。我以为是我笑的方式。我记得。
And I remember I tried to change these things. I tried not to laugh so loud. I tried to cough differently. They made fun of the most minuscule things that are just human, like chewing. If they would've noticed the way that I breathed, they would have made fun of that. I remember I tried lifting weights. And it was impossible, because there was nothing I could do to make them change their minds. If I lifted weights, it was the way that I lifted weights. They would come up with something.
我记得我试图改变这些。我试着别笑得那么大声。我试着换种方式咳嗽。他们嘲笑最微不足道、最人性化的事，比如咀嚼。如果他们注意到我呼吸的方式，他们也会嘲笑那个的。我记得我试过举重。但这根本不可能，因为我无论怎么做都无法改变他们的想法。如果我举重，他们就会嘲笑我举重的方式。他们总能想出点什么。
It was a no-win situation. And I guess I knew how smart he was, and I knew how well he knew me. And I guess, all of a sudden, I had thought that he had seen all these things in me that were just wrong, just so not cool.
这是一个必输的局面。我想我知道他有多聪明，也知道他有多了解我。我猜，突然间，我以为他看到了我身上所有那些不对劲、不酷的地方。
I remember very clearly there was a moment that the clouds just cleared and everything became possible. I went to the Pennsylvania Governor's School for the Arts in my junior year. The summer between my junior and senior year, that was when I met people who were actors, like I was, who were my age and who respected me.
我非常清楚地记得，有那么一刻，云开雾散，一切皆有可能。我高三那年去了宾夕法尼亚州州长艺术学校。那是高三和大四之间的那个夏天，我遇到了跟我一样大的演员，他们尊重我。
And I remember very clearly, it was after lunch, and people who were in my theater class, we were going down to the cafeteria. And I had forgotten my bag in the cafeteria. And I said, "Oh, just wait for me one second. I just want to get my bag." And I went down to the cafeteria, and I got my bag. And I came back up, and they were still there waiting for me. And I remember so distinctly remembering, "Oh, my god. These people, they waited for me."
我记得很清楚，那是午饭后，和我同戏剧班的人要去自助餐厅。我把包忘在餐厅了。我说：“哦，等我一秒钟。我去拿一下包。”我跑下去拿了包，回来时，他们还在等我。我非常清晰地记得那一刻：“天哪。这些人，他们在等我。”
That meant so much to me, because I felt like I'm not this idiot. I'm not this geek. I'm not a person who everyone should hate. I'm actually a pretty good human being, and people like me.
那对我意义重大，因为我感觉我不是那个白痴。我不是那个怪胎。我不是一个每个人都应该讨厌的人。我其实是一个挺好的人，人们喜欢我。
Sometimes, I feel like there's some justice in the fact that I'm surrounded now by many people who love me and respect me. And I don't know how many people he has in his life. But the tables have turned in that way.
有时，我觉得现在身边围绕着许多爱我、尊重我的人，这本身就是一种正义。我不知道他生活中有多少人。但在那方面，情况已经反转了。
And when I go back home and I see people looking at me the way that they looked at me in high school, I think there is some justice in this, because those people are probably-- some of those people, I've heard, are in bad situations with their families. They've got wives they don't love. They've been through divorces. They don't have any friends. They're in the same bar they were in four or five years ago, drinking the same beer they drank. And their gut is a little bigger, and their nose is a little redder. And they just look tired. And I feel like my life is in pretty good shape, and I'm happy. And that's the sweetest revenge. And last Christmas, I ran into him at a mall. And he looked more jaundiced and more sickly than ever.
当我回到家，看到人们用高中时那样的目光看着我时，我觉得这就是正义，因为那些人——我听说有些人过得很糟。他们有不爱的妻子。他们离过婚。没有任何朋友。他们还在四五年前去的那个酒吧里，喝着同样的啤酒。肚子大了一点，鼻子红了一点。他们看起来只是很累。我觉得我的生活状态很好，我很幸福。那是最甜蜜的复仇。去年圣诞节，我在商场遇到了他。他看起来比以往任何时候都更加面黄肌瘦，更加病态。
Bob says that it was because Dave made him an outcast in junior high school that he ended up spending a lot of time with the theater teacher. Because the other kids wouldn't talk to him. And this teacher put him in plays and took him to plays in New York City, showing him that there was a bigger world outside their hometown.
鲍勃说，正是因为戴夫在初中时把他变成了排挤对象，他才最终花了很多时间和戏剧老师在一起。因为其他孩子不跟他说话。这位老师让他参加演出，还带他去纽约看戏，让他看到了家乡之外更广阔的世界。
If it weren't for Dave, I would not be doing what I'm doing right now. There's no way. I don't know what I would have been doing, but because of what he did to me, I found theater, and it's been a really good life so far.
如果不是戴夫，我现在绝对不会做我正在做的事。这不可能。我不知道我会做什么，但因为他对我做的一切，我发现了戏剧，到目前为止，生活一直很好。
Bob's a director in Manhattan. Dave gives his version of the story in Act Three of Your Radio Playhouse .
鲍勃是曼哈顿的一名导演。戴夫在《你的广播剧场》第三幕中讲述了他的故事版本。
Hey, Shirley Jahad?
嘿，雪莉·贾哈德？
Yeah, Ira, man?
是，艾拉？
I love when he says, "I'm going to shoot my buddy."
我喜欢他那句“我要射杀我的哥们儿”。
They're just like, yeah!
他们只是，是的！
The band just goes, like, yeah! They get so excited What a weird moment.
乐队只是，那种感觉，是的！他们太兴奋了。多么诡异的时刻。
Some parts of it are painful, Ira, to listen to. I bet some people have memories of difficulties in their youth.
艾拉，有些部分听起来很痛苦。我敢说有些人对青春期的困难有类似的回忆。
I think if you want to share, we're going to have to set aside more time--
我想如果你想分享，我们得留出更多时间——
Well, I'm not going to share. Don't worry. I won't.
好吧，我不分享。别担心。我不会。
Well, it's OK.
好吧，没关系。
You can call 312-832-3160, and you'll feel absolved of a lot of things. 312-832-3160.
你可以拨打312-832-3160，你会觉得很多事情都得到了解脱。312-832-3160。
And what's that magic word? I keep forgetting it.
魔咒是什么？我一直记不住。
And the magic word, once you call that number, and all the volunteers in that pledge room will know when you say "super size it."
魔咒，一旦你拨打那个号码，所有的志愿者都会知道当你说“升级它”时意味着什么。
It's the disco version of "La Bamba," Shirley.
那是迪斯科版本的《拉班巴》，雪莉。
And all of the volunteers are dirty dancing right now, just so you know.
而且所有的志愿者现在都在跳肮脏舞，让你知道一下。
That's right. If you say the thing about "La Bamba"-- if you say "super size it" for $4.95 extra, any premium this radio station has, including our three special premia tonight-- the Un-Cabaret CD, the David Sedaris tape, and the Shut Up, Little Man CD, they will throw in 90 minutes of various "La Bambas." on top of it.
没错。如果你说了《拉班巴》那个事——如果你额外多捐4.95美元说“升级它”，电台的任何礼品，包括今晚我们三个特别赠品——Un-Cabaret CD、戴维·塞达里斯磁带和《闭嘴，小人》CD，他们都会额外赠送90分钟各种版本的《拉班巴》。
A variety of "La Bambas." 312-832-3160, the number to call to support Your Radio Playhouse . We are looking for new members here on WBEZ in Chicago. And what better place to look than a new program, Your Radio Playhouse , a fantastic new addition to WBEZ's lineup. 312-832-3160. If you've been catching the program the last few shows and enjoying it, then give us a call now. 312-832-3160.
各种版本的《拉班巴》。312-832-3160，致电支持《你的广播剧场》的号码。我们正在芝加哥WBEZ寻找新成员。有什么地方比一个新的节目《你的广播剧场》更适合寻找呢，这是WBEZ节目阵容中一个梦幻般的新增项目。312-832-3160。如果你过去几期节目一直在收听并喜欢它，那就现在打电话给我们。312-832-3160。
And, Shirley, let me play another sample from this Un-Cabaret CD. Again, it's this unusual forum, which isn't exactly stand-up comedy. The comics come and tell stories about their own lives, every week in Los Angeles. If you were to fly to Los Angeles and go to this club, it would cost you hundreds and hundreds of dollars. But for just a $60 pledge, we're going to give you a CD, and for $64.95, a CD plus this fabulous music. And here's a sample of one of the bits. I'll just play it quick so people know what they're getting. This is a guy named Terry Sweeney. No relation to Julia Sweeney.
而且，雪莉，让我播放Un-Cabaret CD里的另一个片段。再说一遍，这是一个不同寻常的论坛，不完全是单口喜剧。喜剧演员每周在洛杉矶讲述他们自己生活的故事。如果你要飞往洛杉矶去那个俱乐部，那会花费你数百美元。但只需承诺捐款60美元，我们就会送你一张CD，64.95美元则送你CD加上美妙的音乐。这是其中的一小段。我会快点放，让人们知道他们会得到什么。这是一个叫泰瑞·斯威尼的人。和朱莉娅·斯威尼没关系。
I used to go to things like The Mine Shaft, which was in New York-- when I lived in New York-- which was much too hardcore for me. And people would be really dressed in these leather harnesses and leather caps and dog collars and totally done up. And I'd have tried to put on a black cardigan or something.
我过去常去类似“矿井”（The Mine Shaft）的地方，在纽约——我住在纽约的时候——对我来说太硬核了。人们穿着皮革束带、皮帽、狗项圈，全副武装。而我试着穿上一件黑色开衫之类的。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
And a mock turtleneck. I thought, "I'll show you. I can do the scene." And I saw these two men. They were just so hardcore. And one had the other one on a leash. Nipples were pinched, and things were hanging in all kinds of apparatus I couldn't even identify. And so I inch close to them because I go, I want to hear what these two are talking about. And I inch behind them, and this guy said, "I just loved that angel cake. It was so moist. Can I have the recipe?" "Well, mother has it on a card. I will write mother and have her send it."
和一件高领毛衣。我想，“我也能跟上这场景。”我看到这两个人。他们真是太硬核了。一个人用皮带牵着另一个。乳头被捏着，身上挂着各种我认不出来的器械。我凑近他们，因为我想听听这两个人在说什么。我悄悄移到他们身后，这人说：“我真喜欢那个天使蛋糕。太湿润了。有食谱吗？”“嗯，母亲有写在卡片上。我会写信给母亲让她寄给你。”
832-3160.
832-3160。
832-3160. 312-832-3160, the number to call. Pledge your support for Your Radio Playhouse , WBEZ's brand new, groovy Friday evening show. 312-832-3160.
832-3160。312-832-3160，拨打电话。承诺支持《你的广播剧场》，这是WBEZ全新的、酷炫的周五晚间节目。312-832-3160。
Again, these are premia-- some of these-- that are only being offered tonight. Shirley, we'll check back with you in a couple minutes.
再说一次，这些赠品——有些——是今晚才提供的。雪莉，我们几分钟后再连线。
Thanks, Ira.
谢谢，艾拉。
Call. Please call. Please call. We are trying to figure out stuff that you might enjoy, now as ever.
打电话。请打电话。请打电话。我们一直在想你们可能会喜欢的东西，现在也一样。
Well, Act Three, Dave's Response. It's an odd thing, actually, as a reporter, calling a stranger on the phone and asking him to defend things he did 15 years before as a teenager. Who amongst us wants to get that call? So I reached Dave at his parents' house, where he still lives. And he's a devout Christian now. He writes and edits a Christian magazine for young people. And he says he's never been happier.
好吧，第三幕，戴夫的回应。作为一名记者，给陌生人打电话，要求他为15年前作为青少年时所做的事情辩解，是一件奇怪的事情。我们中间谁想接到那个电话呢？所以我联系上了还在父母家住的戴夫。他现在是一个虔诚的基督徒。他为年轻人编写和编辑一份基督教杂志。他说他从未如此快乐过。
No, he does not really think about Bob very often. No, Bob is not a big figure in his life. No, he does not remember the fight with Mike. Yes, he remembers being enemies with Bob in the seventh grade. But no, he wasn't sure why. The best that he could remember, Bob was to blame. Bob, by becoming friends with someone else.
不，他并没有经常想起鲍勃。不，鲍勃在他生活中不是个大人物。不，他不记得和迈克的打斗。是的，他记得七年级时和鲍勃成为敌人。但不，他不确定原因。他能记得最清楚的是，鲍勃有错。鲍勃通过和别人成为朋友。
And they were doing these other things. I got really mad and everything, and it was like going from best friends to worst. I'm trying to remember this.
而且他们在做其他事情。我当时真的很生气，感觉从最好的朋友变成了最坏的。我试着记起这个。
And he remembers-- is this also accurate or do you remember this as well? He remembers you turning other people against him. He says that at one point, there was actually a "I Hate [? Cooze ?] Club" that you started.
他还记得——这准确吗，还是你也有印象？他记得你煽动其他人反对他。他说有一次，你确实发起了一个“我恨[？]俱乐部”。
Oh, gosh. Again, I don't even remember that. But now that you say it, gosh, what a terrible person I must've been, because that's horrible. Oh, man, I actually kind of remember that now. That's pretty lame.
哦，天哪。再说一次，我甚至不记得了。但现在你说了，天哪，我当时一定是多么糟糕的人啊，因为那太可怕了。哦，伙计，我确实有点想起来了。那太逊了。
What do you remember of it?
你记得什么？
I don't. That's just it. When you said the name, it's like, oh, my gosh, did I really do that? I have no idea.
我不记得。这就是问题所在。当你提到那个名字时，就像是，哦，天哪，我真的做过那种事吗？我根本不知道。
When he describes you during that period, he felt like you had a kind of David Koresh-like power over others.
当他描述那段时间的你时，他感觉你对其他人有一种大卫·考雷什那样的控制力。
Well, I mean, we were in high school. I'm trying to think of--
嗯，我是说，我们当时在高中。我在试着想——
Can you imagine yourself being seen in that light?
你能想象自己被那样看待吗？
No, not really at all. Looking back now, I feel like I was always the one that was really, totally at the bottom of the social level, or whatever you want to call it, in school. And I'm thinking, I wonder what caused me to do something like that. Obviously, to make myself look better or something, because-- I don't know, but that's pretty bad.
不，真的完全不能。回过头来看，我感觉我总是学校里社交层级最底层的那个人。我在想，到底是什么导致我做了那种事？显然，是为了让自己看起来更好之类的，因为——我不知道，但这真的很糟糕。
I'll tell you the way that Bob remembers and interprets what happened between the two of you. He doesn't remember it as being the kind of thing where he became friends with somebody else. He says that you guys were really, really close-- really close friends. And then, when everybody hit adolescence, a really typical thing happened to you, and that is that other boys started accusing you of being gay. And that you publicly wanted to put a stop to it.
我告诉你鲍勃如何记得和解读你们之间发生的事情。他不记得是因为他和别人成为朋友而变成那样。他说你们当时关系非常非常亲近——非常亲近的朋友。然后，当每个人进入青春期，你们发生了非常典型的事情，就是其他男生开始指责你们是同性恋。而你公开想制止这一切。
Gosh, honestly, I cannot even remember this. He has a much better memory than me. I know we were close and everything, but I don't ever remember any accusations like that. No. And I'm trying to think, too. I'm sitting here trying to drag it out of my memory as to why did we start fighting in the first place? And I'm thinking, but jeez.
天哪，说实话，我甚至都不记得了。他的记忆力比我好得多。我知道我们曾经关系很近，但我一点也不记得有这种指责。不。我也在想，我也坐在这儿试着从记忆深处挖掘，我们到底为什么先打起来的？我在想，天呐。
Actually, the thing that it's making me think about is, in the case of a story like this, I think it's easier for a person who was the injured person-- or believes they were the injured person-- to remember something than the person who did something hurtful. Because I think it's so much more embarrassing to remember yourself as being someone who did something hurtful.
其实，这让我想到，在一个像这样的故事中，我认为对于那个受伤的人——或者认为自己是受伤的人——来说，要记住某些事情比那个做了伤人事情的人要容易得多。因为我觉得记住自己曾做过伤人的事更尴尬。
Right. Now I work with kids that are about that age. And they get in their little spats sometimes. And we just always go to the Bible together. And I try to say, well, look, this person's your friend. We just had an incident like this last week. This one girl, her friends, all of a sudden, just wouldn't talk to her. I felt really bad for this person because she's always one of the gang. I'm thinking, man, I've got to get a hold of her and see what's wrong and everything and get all these people back together, because this isn't good.
对。现在我跟那个年纪的孩子一起工作。他们有时会闹小别扭。我们就总是一起去查圣经。我试着说，看，这人是你的朋友。上周我们刚发生过类似的事情。那个女孩，她的朋友们突然间就不理她了。我真的很为她难过，因为她一直是这帮人里的一个。我心想，天哪，我得联系她，看看出了什么问题，把这些人重新聚在一起，因为这样不好。
[TELEPHONE RINGING]
（电话铃响）
Hello?
喂？
Hi, is Bob there?
你好，鲍勃在吗？
This is Bob.
我是鲍勃。
So after I spoke with Dave, I called Bob. I guess you could figure that out for yourself, huh?
在和戴夫谈过之后，我给鲍勃打了电话。我想你自己能猜到原因吧，对吗？
You describe him going and whispering in people's ear, Iago-like, saying, go do this, go do that, walk up to Bob and say this to him, push him in the locker. And he remembers none of that.
你描述他像伊阿古一样去别人耳边吹风，说，去干这个，去干那个，走到鲍勃面前对他这么说，把他推到储物柜里。但他什么都不记得了。
I remember that very clearly.
我记得非常清楚。
Well, he remembers none of it.
嗯，他什么都不记得了。
I remember it very clearly. That is stuff that scarred me for years and years and years. And it's no surprise that I remember it and he doesn't.
我记得非常清楚。那些伤疤伴随了我多年多年。我不记得他记得不记得，这毫不奇怪。
Thinking about what happened to you, just thinking about it over the last few days, it's really made me think about what it means to love somebody. You know how when you love somebody, you're always more aware of what they do in the room than anybody else?
想想发生在你身上的事，就在过去几天仔细想了想，这真的让我思考爱一个人意味着什么。你知道当你爱一个人时，你总是比任何人更关注他在房间里做了什么，对吧？
And because you guys really loved each other, anything that he would do in a room would be something that would be more apparent to you than what anybody else was doing and would seem more important. So if somebody else were just as influential over other kids in the class, you would always be more aware of what Dave did.
因为你们真心爱过彼此，他房间里的任何动作都会比别人做的更让你注意，也会显得更重要。所以如果其他人对班里的孩子也有同样的影响力，你总会比戴夫做的更关注。
Yeah, I would say all of his activities were illuminated more to me than to anyone else because of that. But I do know that he was the focal point for all this antagonism against me throughout those years. No doubt. He generated it. It didn't just come from nowhere.
是的，我会说比起任何人，他的活动在我眼中都被放大了。但我确实知道，那些年里，他就是反对我的所有对抗行为的焦点。毫无疑问。是他制造了这些。这些并不是无缘无故发生的。
It's an odd thing to have a profound experience with somebody else, a really intimate experience, and you remember every detail. And the other person remembers none of it. And so you're left there alone. When I talked to Bob, I asked him about this over and over and over again because I thought it was such a particular kind of moment for him. But he didn't really take it that way.
和一个人的深刻经历，一段非常亲密的体验，而你记得每一个细节，另一个人却什么都不记得，这很奇妙。所以你只能独自留在那里。和鲍勃谈话时，我一遍又一遍地问他这件事，因为我认为对他来说那是一个非常特别的时刻。但他并不真的那么认为。
I don't know, I have no reason to feel lonely about this. I don't expect Dave to remember it. What you're saying sounds like I should have animosity toward him because of what he did to me.
我不知道，我没理由对此感到孤独。我不指望戴夫能记得。你说的听起来像是我应该因为他对我做的事而对他怀恨在心。
No, I don't mean animosity at all. Actually, in fact, just the opposite. Simply someone else to confirm that it happened. That it happened and that it had a meaning.
不，我完全不是那个意思。事实上，恰恰相反。只是需要有人去确认那件事真的发生了。它发生了，而且它有意义。
Yeah. Yeah, you may be right. Now I feel alone. [LAUGHS] I mean, yeah, I can see myself saying, "But, Dave, don't you remember?" This was a massive event in my life.
是的。是的，你说得对。现在我感到孤独了。（笑）我是说，是的，我能想象自己说：“但是，戴夫，你不记得了吗？”这对我的生命来说是一个重大的事件。
As you were talking, I was thinking this is the Gabriel Garcia Marquez part of the story where, like, is memory lost? Does memory last? Does it mean anything if an entire nation forgets what it was? Or does it mean anything if we are the only one who remembers an experience and then we are lost, and so that experience is never remembered? Does it mean anything? And you're saying, really, no. Maybe it meant something to me, but no, not really.
在你说话时，我想到了这是故事中加西亚·马尔克斯的部分，比如，记忆会消失吗？记忆会持久吗？如果整个国家忘记了它曾经的样子，它还有意义吗？或者如果我们是唯一记得这段经历的人，然后我们也迷失了，这段经历就永远不被铭记了吗？它还有意义吗？你是在说，真的，没意义。也许它对我来说有意义，但真的没意义。
And I can assure you that I am like-- I'm going to pronounce his name wrong, it's Jorge Luis Borges. Like he says, I'm remembering the last time I remembered it, which was a memory of the last time I remembered it, which is a memory of the last time I remembered it. It increasingly gets more and more dramatic, and the moment gets refined down to-- it gets distilled down into something which becomes very palatable and very understandable.
我可以向你保证，我像——我会念错他的名字，是豪尔赫·路易斯·博尔赫斯（Jorge Luis Borges）。就像他说的那样，我记得我上次想起它的时候，那是对上次想起它时的记忆，那是对再上次想起它时的记忆。它变得越来越戏剧化，那一刻被精炼到了——被蒸馏成了一些变得非常容易接受和非常容易理解的东西。
One loose end in the whole thing, of course, was the friend, the mysterious friend. Remember, Dave said that Bob was to blame for them becoming enemies in the seventh grade by making friends with a guy who, we were told, is named Mike, though not the Mike whose wrist Bob later broke.
当然，整件事中一个悬而未决的问题是那个朋友，那个神秘的朋友。记住，戴夫说鲍勃是他们七年级变成敌人的罪魁祸首，因为鲍勃和一个我们被告知叫迈克的家伙交了朋友，尽管不是鲍勃后来打断手腕的那个迈克。
I can sort of understand that. I know which Mike you're referring to, and I know that we did start to become friends then. But the friendship that I had with Dave was always the strongest friendship that I ever had up until probably five years ago when I met the person who I consider my best friend now. He always used to use the term "false friend" in seventh and eighth grade. I remember that clearly. He used to always say I was his "false friend."
我有点能理解。我知道你指的是哪个迈克，我也知道我们那时确实开始成为朋友了。但我与戴夫的友谊一直是我拥有的最深厚的友谊，直到大约五年前我遇到了我现在认为最好的朋友。他总是用“虚假的朋友”这个词，在七、八年级的时候。我记得很清楚。他总是说我是他的“虚假的朋友”。
Meaning what?
什么意思？
Well, what is it? I don't know. What does it mean? It means you were friends, but now it's fake or it's--
嗯，是什么意思？我不知道。它意味着什么？意味着你们曾经是朋友，但现在是假的，或者它——
See, to me, false friend means that he thinks that you betrayed him.
你看，对我来说，虚假的朋友意味着他认为你背叛了他。
Could be. It could be. God, wouldn't that be awful if it all boiled down to one event where he felt like me and Mike were becoming friends, and it could've been cleared up in one conversation?
可能是。可能是。上帝，如果这一切归结为一件事，即他感觉我和迈克正在成为朋友，并且这一切本来可以在一次谈话中解决，那该有多糟糕。
That it was a complete misunderstanding.
这完全是一个误解。
That it was just a total tiny misunderstanding that could have been cleared up?
这是一个本来可以解决的完全微小的误解？
Happens all the time.
这种事总是发生。
Boy, I would just love to see what my life would have been like if that would have happened.
天哪，如果那件事发生了，我真想看看我的生活会是什么样。
In Act Four, another perspective on the whole thing from David Sedaris. But first, let's go to Pledge Central. Shirley Jahad.
第四幕，来自戴维·塞达里斯关于这件事的另一个视角。但首先，让我们去捐款中心。雪莉·贾哈德。
Ira Glass.
艾拉·格拉斯。
Hi, honey.
你好，亲爱的。
Hi, sweetie.
你好，甜心。
I understand that we're having problems with the phones.
我了解到我们电话出了问题。
We have demons, demons on the pledge lines. Maybe Bob or somebody has infiltrated here. Anyway, the number is 312-832-3160. If you're having trouble getting through, please be patient and do not give up on us. 312-832-3160 to pledge your support for Your Radio Playhouse. on WBEZ Chicago. Now, I understand some people are calling and it's ringing, but we're not hearing it ring here. And eventually we do hear it ring, but that's after several minutes.
我们的捐款热线有恶魔，恶魔。也许鲍勃或什么人渗透到这儿了。不管怎样，号码是312-832-3160。如果你无法打通，请保持耐心，不要放弃我们。312-832-3160来承诺对芝加哥WBEZ《你的广播剧场》的支持。现在，我了解到有人在打电话，电话在响，但我们这边没听到声音。最终确实听到了，但那是几分钟之后的事了。
So if you're having trouble getting through, and if you don't get through until the exact moment when our show ends, and you want some of the premia from this hour and the phones aren't working, ask for them and we'll give them to you.
所以如果你打不进来，如果你直到我们节目结束的那一刻才打进来，如果你想要这个小时的赠品而电话又不通，就说出它们，我们会给你的。
That's right. 312-832-3160.
没错。312-832-3160。
Here we go. Here's something we haven't played yet. Again, we have special premia. One is the Un-Cabaret CD. One is the Shut Up, Little Man CD, which maybe I'll just play a little clip of that real fast. It's a very odd CD-- these two guys who would fight all the time. And it's sort of audio verite recorded by their neighbors next door as these two men would scream at each other. Here we go.
我们要开始了。这是我们还没放过的东西。再说一次，我们有特别赠品。一个是Un-Cabaret CD。一个是《闭嘴，小人》CD，也许我只是快速放一小段。这CD非常古怪——这两个人总是吵架。这算是音频真实记录，是邻居录下来的，这两个男人总是互相尖叫。开始了。
--cut your toenails, so why would I worry about it? For god's sakes, shut up, little man. I don't want to watch you cut your toenails. I would liked to have eaten tonight also, but I can't because of you talking about toenails.
——剪你的脚趾甲，所以我为什么要担心？看在上帝的份上，闭嘴吧，小人。我不想看你剪脚趾甲。我也想今晚吃顿饭，但因为你一直在说脚趾甲，我吃不了。
Now, I should say the music in there is actually from our little mix that we did on the show. And this is one of those things that it's hard to get a sense of just in a brief little clip. Another thing we're giving away is recent work by beloved NPR commentator David Sedaris. And that includes work that he's done here on Your Radio Playhouse , that is, some of the radio plays he's done with his sister, Amy, and other actors. And this piece, this half-hour hitchhiking story that he told. Here's one little brief, brief episode from that story.
现在，我应该说里面的音乐其实是我们节目中自己混音的。这是一段很难从简短剪辑中感受到的东西。我们送出的另一件东西是受人爱戴的NPR评论员戴维·塞达里斯的近期作品。那包括他曾在《你的广播剧场》中做过的工作，也就是他和妹妹艾米及其他演员做的一些广播剧。还有这篇，他讲述的半小时搭车故事。这里是那个故事里的一小段、一小段。
I got an interminable ride with a pantyhose salesman who spent six hours saying "You just take and take, don't you? Don't you? Out there with your thumb in the air, not a care in the world, grabbing whatever you can get. Yes, sir, you take and you take until you're ready to burst. But what about giving? Did you ever think about that? Of course not. You're too busy taking.
我搭了一个连珠炮似的连裤袜推销员的车，他花了六个小时说：“你只是一味索取，不是吗？不是吗？在外头竖着大拇指，什么都不管，想方设法捞好处。是的，先生，你索取，索取，直到快要爆炸。但付出呢？你有没有想过那个？当然没有。你太忙于索取了。
Me, I'm what you call a taxpayer. Tax, it's a tariff that working people have to pay so that someone like you can enjoy a life of leisure. I give, and I give until I've got nothing left. Then I turn right around, and I give some more. I give and give to all of Uncle Sam's little takers. And I've been thinking that maybe it's about time I get a little something in return. Yes, indeed. Maybe it's time we try that shoe on the other foot for a change. You, my young friend, are going to wash my car, inside and out, and you're going to pay for it."
我呢，我是所谓的纳税人。税，是劳动人民不得不支付的关税，好让像你这样的人能享受闲适的生活。我付出，我一直付出直到一无所有。然后我回过头，再多付出一点。我给予那些山姆大叔的小索取者们。我一直在想，也许是时候我得到一点回报了。是的，确实。也许是时候让我们换位思考了。你，我年轻的朋友，你要把我的车从里到外洗干净，而且你要自己付钱。”
Anyway, again, the number if you want this very odd collection of stories from David Sedaris, 832-3160. The collection includes the story that we're going to hear at the end of this evening's show.
总之，再说一遍，如果你想要这套戴维·塞达里斯非常古怪的故事集，832-3160。这套藏品包括我们今晚节目最后要听的故事。
312-832-3160. Call now to pledge your support for Your Radio Playhouse , a place where you hear David Sedaris' stories in their entirety, the uncut versions you will get on that cassette that you can get for a $60 pledge. 312-832-3160. Be patient, and let that phone ring, and we will get to you as soon as we can.
312-832-3160。现在就打电话来承诺支持《你的广播剧场》，在这里你可以听到戴维·塞达里斯故事的完整版，你承诺捐款60美元就能在磁带上得到那些未剪辑版本。312-832-3160。保持耐心，让电话响起来，我们会尽快接通你。
We put a lot of effort into this show to bring you unusual stories that you will not hear anywhere else. And we want your support. We want your support. And we were trying to find premia that you would enjoy and could get nowhere else. So please, please call. Please call and join our fun little party here. And I guess that's it. 832-3160.
我们为这个节目付出了很多努力，带给你们在其他任何地方都听不到的独特故事。我们需要你们的支持。我们需要你们的支持。我们一直在寻找你们会喜欢且其他地方得不到的赠品。所以请，请拨打电话。请拨打并加入我们这个有趣的小派对吧。我想就是这样了。832-3160。
312-832-3160. And take it, Ira. I guess we'll go on.
312-832-3160。接下去吧，艾拉。我想我们继续。
Well, Act Four. Act Four of this evening's program is called Another Dave. And this story by David Sedaris, frequent Morning Edition commentator, member of the Pinetree Gang, contributor to this program. And this is a story of ultimate Machiavellian scheming. It's kind of an endpoint as to how far you can go. It's called "The Last Time You'll Ever Hear from Me." It's a story, and it's read by Sarah Thyre.
好吧，第四幕。今晚节目的第四幕叫“另一个戴夫”。这个故事由戴维·塞达里斯所著，他是频繁出现的《早间版》评论员，松树帮成员，本节目的撰稿人。这是一个终极马基雅维利阴谋的故事。它是关于你能走多远的终点。它叫“最后一次听我说话”。这是一个故事，由萨拉·泰尔朗读。
Dear friends and family, by the time you receive this letter, I will be dead. Those of you attending this service are sitting quietly holding a beautiful paperweight, a gift from the collection which, in life, had been my pride and joy. You turn the paperweight over in your hands, look deep inside at the object embedded in the glass, be it a rose or a scorpion, whatever. And through your tears, you ask, what is death like?
亲爱的朋友和家人，当你们收到这封信时，我已经死了。参加葬礼的你们正安静地坐着，手里拿着一个美丽的纸镇，那是从我生前引以为傲的收藏品中挑选出来的礼物。你们把纸镇翻过来，深情地看着嵌入玻璃里的物体，不论是玫瑰还是蝎子，什么的。透过眼泪，你们问，死后是什么样的？
By this time, I certainly know the answer to that question, but I'm unable to give details. Know only that I will one day meet you upon the grassy plains of heaven where, with the exception of Randy Sykes and Annette Kelper, I will be tickled to embrace you and catch up on all the news.
到那时候，我当然知道那个问题的答案，但我无法透露细节。只要知道总有一天我会在天堂的草地上与你们相见，除了兰迪·赛克斯和安妮特·凯尔珀之外，我会很高兴地拥抱你们，叙叙旧。
If my instructions were followed the way I wanted them to be-- see attached instruction envelope number one-- this letter is being read to you from the pulpit of the Simple Shepherd Church of Christ by my best friend, Eileen Mickey-- hi, Eileen-- who is wearing the long-sleeve Lisa Montino designer dress I left behind that always looked so good on me.
如果我的指令如我所愿被执行——看附件指令信封一——这封信正由我最好的朋友艾琳·米奇通过简单牧羊人基督教堂的讲坛读给你们听——嗨，艾琳——她穿着我留下的那件Lisa Montino长袖设计师裙子，那裙子穿在我身上总是显得很棒。
Eileen, I hope you either lost some weight or took it out some on the sides, or you're not going to be able to breathe. Also remember, it needs to be dry cleaned. I know how you and your family love to skimp. But please, don't listen to what anyone says about Woolite. Dry clean.
艾琳，我希望你要么减肥了，要么把它改宽了，否则你穿不进去。还要记住，它需要干洗。我知道你和你的家人多喜欢省钱。但请千万别听别人说的什么Woolite洗涤剂。干洗。
Most of you are probably wondering why I did it. You're whispering, "Why, Lord? Why take Trish Moody? Trish was a ray of bright sunshine, always so up and perky and full of love. Pretty, too. Just as smart and sweet and pretty as they come."
你们大多数人大概在想为什么我要这么做。你们在耳语：“上帝啊，为什么？为什么要带走翠西·穆迪？翠西是一束明亮的阳光，总是那么积极、活泼、充满爱心。长得也漂亮。聪明、甜美、漂亮，要什么有什么。”
You're probably shaking your heads and thinking there's plenty of people a lot worse than Trish Moody. There's her former excuse for a boyfriend, Randy Sykes, for example. The boyfriend who, after Trish accidentally backed her car over his dog, practically beat her senseless. He beat her with words, but still, it might as well have been with his fists. He struck her again and again with words and names such as "manipulative," "jealous," "childish," and others I wouldn't justify in print. The dog's death was a tragic accident, but perhaps also a blessing in disguise, as Randy tended to spend entirely too much time with it.
你们大概在摇头，觉得世界上比翠西·穆迪坏的人多的是。比如她以前那个叫兰迪·赛克斯的男朋友。那个男朋友在翠西不小心倒车轧死他的狗后，几乎把她打得半死。他是用语言打的，但尽管如此，那也和拳头打的没区别了。他一次又一次地用“操纵”、“嫉妒”、“幼稚”以及其他我不屑印在纸上的脏话攻击她。狗的死是个悲惨的意外，但也可能是一种变相的祝福，因为兰迪花在它身上的时间实在是太多了。
What did Trish's mother say when her daughter, heartbroken over her breakup with Randy, came to her in search of love and understanding? If you're looking for sympathy, you can find it between "sob story" and "syphilis" in the dictionary. Perhaps my mother can live with slogans such as this. I know I can't.
当翠西的女儿，因为与兰迪分手而心碎，寻求母爱和理解时，她妈妈说了什么？如果你想找同情心，字典里“苦情故事”（sob story）和“梅毒”（syphilis）之间能找到。也许我母亲能忍受这样的口号。我知道我不能。
Neither can I live surrounded by friends such as Annette Kelper. Poor, chubby Annette Kelper, who desperately tries to pretend that nobody notices the fact that she's balding on top of her head. That's right. Look closely. Balding, just like a man.
我也无法忍受被安妮特·凯尔珀这样的朋友包围。可怜、胖乎乎的安妮特·凯尔珀，拼命假装没人注意到她头顶秃了的事实。没错。仔细看看。秃了，就像个男人一样。
Perhaps Randy feels sorry for chrome-dome Annette. Maybe that's why he was seen twice in her company in a single five-day period. Seen standing together in the parking lot of the Burger Tabernacle-- her home away from home-- and seen huddled together, laughing on the escalator of the Crabtree Valley Mall. Annette, my supposed best friend, who secretly wanted and coveted everything I owned. Is everyone on earth as two-faced as Annette Kelper? Is everyone as cruel as Randy Sykes? I think not.
也许兰迪同情那个“秃头”安妮特。也许这就是为什么他在五天内两次被看到和她在一起。被看到在汉堡会幕——她的第二个家——的停车场站在一起，被看到在克拉布特里谷购物中心的自动扶梯上一起嬉笑。安妮特，我所谓的最好的朋友，背地里却想要并觊觎我拥有的一切。世界上每个人都像安妮特·凯尔珀一样两面三刀吗？每个人都像兰迪·赛克斯一样残忍吗？我想不是。
Most of you, the loved ones I left behind, are simple, devoted people. I urge you now to take a look around the room. Are Randy Sykes and Annette sitting in the audience? Are they shifting uncomfortably in the pew, shielding their faces with the 8 and 1/2 by 11 photograph of me I had reproduced to serve as a memento of this occasion?
你们大多数人，我留下的亲人，都是简单、忠诚的人。我现在敦促你们环顾四周。兰迪·赛克斯和安妮特在观众席里吗？他们是在长椅上不安地挪动，用我为了这个场合特意翻印的8.5乘11的照片挡住脸吗？
Eileen, read this part real fast before they have a chance to leave. Randy Sykes' drip is the size of my little finger, and that's when it's hard. And I'm not counting the nail-- just the finger. He had sex two times with a boy at Camp Ticonderoga when he was in junior high school. Maybe that explains why he loves it with somebody sticks their finger up his [? couvade. ?] He used to beg me to do that, but I refused. I said, "No way, Randy." He used to do it to himself all the time. That's why I never held hands with him. His hands stink.
艾琳，快点读这一段，别给他们离开的机会。兰迪·赛克斯的阴茎也就我小指那么大，这还是硬的时候。我没算指甲——只算手指。他在初中时曾在蒂康德罗加营地和一个男孩发生过两次性行为。也许这就是为什么他喜欢有人用手指捅他的[？]。他过去常求我那么做，但我拒绝了。我说：“没门，兰迪。”他过去总是自己那样做。这就是我从不和他牵手的原因。他的手很臭。
He secretly thinks he looks like Marlon Brando, but take a good look. A young Marlin Perkins is more like it. Maybe that's what he sees in Annette Kelper. He's an animal lover. She used to come to my house crying. Her breath smelled a mile off, like her uncle's drip. She said he forced her, but that's a lie, because you don't force whores. And that's what she is, a whore.
他背地里认为自己长得像马龙·白兰度，但请仔细看看。更像个年轻的马林·帕金斯。也许这就是他在安妮特·凯尔珀身上看到的。他是个动物爱好者。她过去常来我家哭。她的口气隔着一里路就能闻到，像她叔叔的阴茎味。她说他强迫她，但那是谎言，因为你不需要强迫妓女。而她就是，一个妓女。
Annette and Randy deserve each other. Drip-Breath and Stinky-Finger, riding up and down the escalator at Crabtree Valley, up and down, up and down. Fancy little shuck-cutlets. Look at them. Take a good, hard look at them. It's their fault I'm dead. They are to blame.
安妮特和兰迪天生一对。口臭和臭手，在克拉布特里谷的自动扶梯上一上一下，上一上一下。虚伪的小人。看看他们。好好盯着他们看。我死是他们的错。他们罪有应得。
I urge you now to take those paperweights and stone them. Release your anger. The Bible says it's all right to cast the first stone if someone dead is telling you do it. And I'm telling you now. Pretend the paperweights are stones and cast them upon the guilty. I put aside my savings to pay for the damages to the walls and windows. It's money I was saving for my wedding, and there's plenty of it. So throw. Hurt them the way they hurt me. Kill them! Nobody will hold you responsible. Kill them!
我现在敦促你们拿着那些纸镇，砸死他们。释放你们的怒火。圣经上说，如果死者叫你这么做，扔下第一块石头也是可以的。而我现在就在告诉你们。把纸镇当成石头，投向那些罪人。我预留了积蓄来赔偿墙壁和窗户的损坏。这是我存来结婚的钱，非常充足。所以扔吧。像他们伤害我那样伤害他们。杀了他们！没人会追究你们的责任。杀了他们！
Eileen, I'm going to allow a few minutes here because it might take a while for certain people to get into the swing of it. Pop in the cassette marked "Stoning," and wait until both Randy and Annette are lifeless. Wait until everyone is finished with their paperweights. And then I want you to hand the microphone over to my mother. Watch the way she trembles and stutters, and remember every gesture as if you were me.
艾琳，我留出几分钟时间，因为有些人可能需要一点时间才能进入状态。插上写着“石刑”的磁带，等着兰迪和安妮特都没了气息。等着每个人都用完他们的纸镇。然后我要你把麦克风交给我的母亲。看着她颤抖和结巴的样子，记住每一个动作，就像你就是我一样。
832-3160. Shirley Jahad? Well, I guess you're not there.
832-3160。雪莉·贾哈德？嗯，我想你不在那儿。
I'm here, Ira.
我在，艾拉。
You are?
是吗？
You know, our volunteers are so resourceful.
你知道，我们的志愿者真是足智多谋。
And are they getting phone calls in?
他们接到电话了吗？
They are taking your phone calls now. 312-832-3160.
他们现在正在接听你们的电话。312-832-3160。
OK, you can get that story, which was from David Sedaris' book Barrel Fever , read by Sarah Thyre, plus also lots of other David Sedaris work, a 90-minute cassette full of all sorts of stuff.
好了，你可以得到那个故事，那是来自戴维·塞达里斯的书《桶中热》（Barrel Fever），由萨拉·泰尔朗读，加上许多其他戴维·塞达里斯的作品，一盘90分钟的磁带，塞满了各种各样的素材。
For just $60. 312-832-3160.
只需60美元。312-832-3160。
Or the two CDs that we've been plugging all hour. I should also mention that David is going to be here in Chicago, live this coming Saturday night at the Park West for Milly's Orchid Show. You might want to go see him there.
或者我们整个小时都在推介的那两张CD。我还应该提到，戴维这个周六晚上将在芝加哥，在公园西部的“米莉兰花秀”（Milly's Orchid Show）现场演出。你们可能想去看看。
Cool.
酷。
Yeah.
是的。
312-832-3160. Call now and what, Ira?
312-832-3160。现在打电话，然后呢，艾拉？
And pledge your support. Remember, this is the only time you're going to get during the drive to get most of these premia and super size it.
并承诺你的支持。记住，这是活动期间你唯一能得到大部分赠品并升级它的机会。
Super size it.
升级它。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
（资金鸣谢）
Today's program was produced by Peter Clowney and myself with Dolores Wilber, Alix Spiegel, and Nancy Updike, contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Paul Tough. Paul Tough did the fabulous original interview with Bob featured in the first half of this program. WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia.
今天的节目由彼得·克劳尼和我制作，多洛雷斯·威尔伯、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普戴克共同贡献，策划编辑杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和保罗·塔夫。保罗·塔夫完成了本节目上半部分中关于鲍勃的精彩原创访谈。WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（致谢）
To buy a tape of this or other Playhouse shows, call us at WBEZ, 832-3380, or email us, [email protected] . We broadcast proudly from WBEZ Chicago. We'll be back next week with more stories of This American Life. See you then.
购买本节目或其他《剧场》节目的磁带，请致电WBEZ，832-3380，或发邮件至[email protected]。我们骄傲地从芝加哥WBEZ广播。下周我们将带着更多关于“这就是美国生活”的故事回来。到时见。